Jack Alex Martins with you Orlando Magic
I hear you've been waiting for a phone
call from us and the wait is over on
behalf of the dasas family and myself
and all of us here at the Orlando Magic
we want to congratulate you as we make
you the first jersey number retired in
the history of the Orlando Magic you had
a great career here at the beginning of
your career and we had some great times
you took us all the way to the NBA
finals and it's finally time to put that
number up in the rafters so
congratulations on behalf of all of us
we look forward to having you here in
Orlando to
celebrate
[Applause]
[Music]
hey impressive confetti action right
there how about that yo man people have
to clean this crap up
yeah the um congratulations b as Alex
Martin pointed out too it's Orlando one
of the few franchises in the leag
that does not have a retired jersey they
tried to wait him out he was gone you
know what's funny so a couple years ago
they did the Ring of Honor and I thought
I was kep my jersey retired so when I
went there I'm I'm I'm waiting to do the
thing so they take me like on the top
floor and they just have like a wall
they did this thing they did the Press I
was like that's it I was like I thought
I was get my J like man we don't do that
here so but I I would like to thank uh
the divorc family I wish the old man was
still alive Rich of all so he he meant a
lot to me him and his family uh you know
Brian Hill D Scott Nick and all those
guys Penny Hardway you know we had great
times there I was I was Victor Wim
before before him oh and what way in
what way y'all both black no you uh come
in they expect you to turn things around
okay you know you have a lot ofure lot
of hype coming in obviously a lot of
hype coming in and so you know our first
year we went 41 and 41 we I think think
we had a 19 20 20 game better than a
year before uh then the next year got uh
substantially better then the third year
we had horse Grant we made it to the
finals where we got Sweat by Kenny but
it was a great four years there and I
just wanted to come in and just you know
make a name for myself also got to think
guys like Charles and Michael and Magic
because you know Ernie when you came to
my house to interview me I still was
that 18-year-old kid who wanted to be
like Charles Barkley and those guys so
when I got drafted by Orlando and I was
finally there I just wanted to represent
so like to thank uh the city of Orlando
like to thank the Orlando Magic
organization appreciate you very much
just wish the old man I wish my father
was here I know that they would have
been proud but thank you and I'll see
you soon deserve Fe February 13th at
February 13th at the newly renamed Kia
Center what day what that's a Tuesday
you get a car it's a it's a Tuesday it's
it's the arena which was a I know I you
know I got a kid boy you better hey talk
to my boy person we'll get you a tell
you ride hey when you uh dog on Drive
kiss when you think back when you're 20
years old and you're stepping on an NBA
floor for the first time um and you
spent your first four years there what
you I mean what did you learn Shaq and
what would you know when you came in
maybe thinking the league was one thing
what did you learn I learned that it was
easier than I thought it was oh really
oh really yeah and and what way what way
was like you watch these guys on TV like
always say how terrified I was of of
Michael Jordan so you know he he came
and he came close I tried to block a
shot I didn't block it but I was there
so now I was like okay he's he's human
just like I am he just a little bit
better human but he's hum you know one
day I'm going catch him but you know I
just wanted to come in make a name for
myself my my mother Dr luil used to
always tell me son make him remember
your name and growing up you know what
what I had similar to all these guys I
had a beautiful basketball name Charles
Barkley Kenny Johnson Ernie Johnson
Michael Jordan my my name is Shaquille
O'Neal so my mom said baby whenever you
play make him remember your name so well
mine is Kenny Smith you ain't remember
mine I wasn't talking much that's why I
said
KY I only working with you for 20 years
you still say no Kenny Johnson you uh
you bring up your mother and wouldn't
you know sha we just happen to have a
message congratulations Shaquille on
retirement of your jersey with the
Orlando Magic of course this is your
number one fan saying congratulations to
you I can remember back when they called
your name Orlando Magic with the first
pick and they picked Shaquille O'Neal we
were all so happy for you as well as
excited and I have to tell you you made
us all proud with all of that
joy and excitement you brought to the
Orlando
Community this award and this
recognition is well deserve so we want
you to enjoy it we're so proud of you
and we pray that you continue to enjoy
life and don't ever forget the memories
God bless you my
son why is your mom so calm and cerebral
you're such an
ass
I got a serious question yeah go ahead
you know how much I love your mom yeah
what kind of doctor is she uh doctor and
uh a business man and you a doctor too
yes I a is that just something y'all
just throwing y'all name for hyper HB no
we what verbally spell it Hy
verbally I would put down any you give
me no she went to school she went to
school yeah and you know what funny
story about that she she calls me one
day she said bee I need to borrow some
money and I'm like why mama has a great
allowance she said I want to go back to
school and I said what you need to go
back to school she said it's something I
always wanted to do I had you when I was
16 had to give up my dreams to you know
make sure was okay so she went she went
uh and got her bachelor's she got her uh
Master's and then she got her doctorate
from Bon cookman HBC wow so yeah spell
hyperbole yeah doctor doctor any chance
Lucille you know I love you any chance